TIME THAT'S ON HIM. OH MY
GOODNESS. TEAM IS THE LETTER
ALL RIGHT SO I AM GOING SHE I
AM GO TO CALL THIS APPROVED
GIVE TO ORDER AND I'M GONNA
MAKE A FEW NOW FOR WE CALL THE
ROLL GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
OBVIOUSLY ONCE THE COVER
NINETEEN SEE HUNDRED PUBLIC.
SENATOR AND STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN A
YEAR TO SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE BORDERS
SENATE WILL BE HOLDING AN
ESSENTIAL HEARING AND IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEAD IN A PROCESS FOR
CONDUCTING THE HERE. IN A WAY.
THE HELP FIFTY THE PUBLIC. ARM
FOR IS NOT WE COMPLY WITH
ORDERS. WERE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HE IN THE CAP WE ARE
ALL A LOT STREAMING. THE
HEARING SO MEMBERS THE PUBLIC'S.
IN SENATE STAY. MAY FOLLOW.
FROM A DISTANCE. AS REMINDER TO
EVERYONE OUT THERE TODAY'S
HEARINGS CONSISTS ONLY. OF
ITEMS THAT ARE ON THE SUSPENSE
FILE. ALL OF THE ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA THIS MORNING. HAVE
ALREADY HAD A HEARING. IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND HAVE ALREADY HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY THIS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR THE PUBLIC. TO
OFFER TESTIMONY BOTH FOR AND
AGAINST. THESE BILLS AS NOTED
IN THE DAILY FILE THE SUSPENSE
FILE HEARING. IS A VOTE ONLY
HEARING AND WE ARE TAKING NO.
TESTIMONY I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW. THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE
HAVING ANOTHER HEARING NEXT
TUESDAY. HE'LL DO HERE- ACA'S
AN S. C. A.'S AND AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR OF SCA
SIX- THAT HAS BEEN MOVED TO
NEXT TUESDAY AS WELL. AND I
BELIEVE THE AUTHOR IS HOPEFUL-
THAT IN THIS IN A ROOM THE
NEGOTIATE INS WITH ALL PARTIES
CAN A BAND. FROM A LIMITED
NUMBER OF FOLKS IN FOOD. OF ALL
LARGE SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZED-
TRIBAL TO TEA. AND WITH THE
AUTHORS THAT'S THE WHOLE AND SO
THAT IT BEEN MOVED TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH ALL THE OTHER.
AC PAYS OR WE'RE GOING TO HEAR.
TUESDAY. WELL I'M ALSO I THANK
MY. HELLO SIR AND SISTER CENTER
FOR THE THERE'S AND MY STEP ON
A PER PER COMMITTEE FOR ALL
OTHER. THROUGH THIS PROCESS AND
I'D LIKE TO HAVE A SPECIAL TO
OUR VICE CHAIR CENTER BATES AND
HER FOR SCHOOLS THAT AS WELL
FOR THE COOPERATION CLASS
ACTION THROUGH THIS TO
INTERESTING SO AND ALL SIDES OF
DONE ANNOUNCED JOB BEFORE WE
BEGIN I'D LIKE TO MAKE A FEW
BRIEF ANNOUNCEMENTS AND HOW WE
APPROACH. THE MAN OF THE PUBLIC
SENATORS AND FOLLOW ALONG WILL
BE MOVING QUICKLY THROUGH THE
AGENDA ALPHABETICALLY IN ALL
THE ORDER PAY CLOSE ATTENTION
AS WE WILL ONLY BE ADDRESSING
MEASURES THAT WILL BE UP FOR
ABOUT THIS MORNING IF YOU DON'T
HEAR ME TAPE TAKE UP A
PARTICULAR MEASURE THAT BILL BE
HELD UNDER SUBMISSION WILL ALSO
ANNOUNCED AUTHOR YOUR NUMBER
PROVIDE A BRIEF CAPTION HAVE
AMENDMENT. TO THE BEFORE WE
TAKE A VOTE. FOLLOWING POSTED
THE HEARING WHERE AT ALL THE
ACTIONS TO ON EACH MEASURE ON
THE SENATOR PER COMMITTEE WEB
IN ADDITION FOR ANY BILLS THAT
ARE AMEND TODAY WE WILL BE
HOSTING A ATTEND AND NOW. WHICH
WHICH INCLUDES A SUMMARY OF THE
MEMO AND THE REVISED FISKE
IMPACT. OF THE AMENDED SO LET'S
ESTABLISH COR MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. YOU KNOW
I'M HERE THEY THERE HERE
BRADFORD YOUR BRADFORD HERE
HELLO YOUR BILL HE JONES JONES
HERE LEYVA. LEYVA HERE LIKE I
HERE CASKEY HERE EVERYONE'S BUT-
ALL RIGHT WE A CORE OF HOUSE
WE'RE GOING TO THROUGH THIS
VERY BAND. ALL RIGHT ONE
PROCEDURAL QUESTION JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE NORMALLY WE HAVE- A
DIFFERENT SYSTEM WHEN WE ARE
NOT SOCIALLY JUSTICE SO. THE
FIRST ITEM OF FOR US IS SB TEN
FORTY FOUR POINT ALAN. ON FIRE
FIGHTERS EQUIPMENT AND PHONE-
THIS IS A DO PASS AS AMENDED.
DELAY STOMACH BASIN DATE FORM
PUBLIC ENTITIES EARLIER AND
LIMIT THE RECALL OF HOME TO
ONLY WHAT IS SOLD AFTER THE
BILL. TAKES EFFECT THERE ARE
ALSO. GOING CONVERSATIONS
BETWEEN THE AUTHOR AND
INTERESTED PARTIES AND I'M
OPTIMISTIC THAT THEY WILL BE
FRUITFUL AND PRODUCTIVE AS THIS
MOVES FORWARD THROUGH THE
PROCESS. SO THE FACT AS AMENDED
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. A MEASURE
SB TWO FORTY THE MOST IS DEEP
TO HAVE AMEND TO THE A SENATE
FLOOR. CENTER TWENTY AYE
PORTANTINO BY BATES. BRADFORD
EFFORT BY HILL HILL I JONES I
STRONGLY STAYING AT. LEYVA HI
LEYVA I MY COUNTY HI THE
CASCADE PARK MEASURES FIVE
EIGHTHS THE BILL IS OUT. FIVE
VOTES ROOM ON MISTER TO LET IT
EIGHT NINETY ZERO MISSION FOR
IN FOR THE IS A TWO. SB EIGHT
NINETY FIVE A MONTH TO PASS TO
THIS FLOOR PORTANTINO I
PORTANTINO HI BAY. BATES HI
BRAD. BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL HI
JOAN JONES I LEYVA HI LEYVA BY
MY COUNTY. HI THE CASKET
SEVENTH THE BILL IS OUT WHAT'S
WHAT'S SOME VOTERS NINE OF CHOI
ABUSE BEST MILLET NOTED. IS A
DO PASS SB NINE SO EMOTIONS
PASS THE SENATE FLOOR PORTENT I
PORTANTINO ON BATES BATES I
BRADFORD BRADFORD ON HILL HILL.
MY ON BATTERIES ILLEGAL
DISPOSAL FIRE PREVENTION-
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHORED REQUIRE
CAL RECYCLE THE POST GUIDELINE
GUIDANCE ON ITS WEBSITE IN LIEU
OF PUBLIC INFORMATION CAMPAIGN.
MEASURES AT ELEVEN FIFTY SIX
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
FORTINO I BATES BATES FIVE.
BRADFORD I. HILL HI JONES JR I
LAY I LEYVA HI WHAT CAN HI MY
COUNTY. MEASURES OF THE BILL IS
OUT IS A MOVING ON THEM IS AT
SP NINE NINE FIVE JOBS.
IMPROVEMENT THE INVITE LEADERS
FACTOR TWO ELEVEN STE TO PASS.
THE NINE NINE FIVE THE MOST TO
PAY THE SAN FLOOR. I PORTANTINO
I. BATES AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE HILL. HILL AYE JOE. JONES
HI LEYVA I LEYVA I COUNTY HI I
CAN ARE MEASURES SEVEN BY. THE
BILL IS OUT SO IS SB ELEVEN
TWENTY DUPLEX AN HERB LOTS.
MINISTERIAL APPROVAL THURMOND
FOR ALL AT JOIN OUR PRO CERTAIN.
CONSECUTIVE BURKE LOTS RIVER
THE DEATH OF TRANSIT AND MAKE
TECHNICAL AND CLARIFY LANGUAGE.
THE MEASURE AS BILL TWENTY
MOTION IS PASS A AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FOR PORTANTINO. HI DO ON
BATES. MY VICE CHAIR SB NINE
THIRTY FOR CORPORATE TAX EXEMPT
ORGANIZATION FILING FEES IT'S
AN AMENDMENT. TO ADD A CO
AUTHOR. MEASURES SB NINE THREE
FOUR MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE OR PORTANTINO HI.
PORTANTINO AYE BATES BATES AYE
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE
HILL AYE JONES JONES HI LEYVA
HI LEYVA HI WERE CASKEY HI I
CASKEY NINE. SEVEN VOTES. THE
BILL WAS OUT SEVEN MISTER BELL
SB NINE ACTION BE SEVEN NINETY
FIVE HOUSING ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND CLIMATE CHANGE-INFRASTRUCTURE AMENDMENTS PER
AUTHORED ALLOW 5% OF THE FUNDS
BE USED FOR STATE MINISTRATION
COST AND REVISE FUNDING OUR
PATIENTS THERE'S A SO.
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE ALLOCATION
CONTINGENT UPON CREATION. SB
SEVEN NINETY FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI I'M
TINA ALL RIGHT BATES GAINES.
BOB BAFFERT ARE BRADFORD AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES. JON SNOW
LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE MAKOWSKI HI
DOES HE ARE. VOTE IS FIVE TWO
ONE THE BILL WAS OUT FIVE TWO
ONE MOVING ON SB EIGHT OH THREE
PEER SUPPORT SPECIALIST
CERTIFICATION- RECOMMENDATION
IS TO MOVE THE BILL TO THE
FLOOR WITH A MAP PER AUTHOR TO
AUTHORIZE A FEET. COVER
ILLUSTRATIVE COST. EIGHT OH
THREE THEM THIS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE CENTER OR TINA
I'VE LEARNED TINA ARE BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD ARE BRADFORD
I. HE I JONES JOE I LEYVA. I
LAY HI WHAT CAN HI HEALTHY ARE.
SEVENTY THE BILL IS ABOUT SO
ZERO MOVING ON AS NINE
CALIFORNIA CONNECTIONS TO
SUCCESS ACT THAT BILL IS A
RECOMMENDED THE PAST WITH THE
MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO CONFORM
TO TRAILER BILL PROPOSAL. SB
NINE TWELVE THE MOTION TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO. BY PORTANTINO ON
BATES AYE BATES AYE BRADFORD
PARK BRADFORD ARE HILL HILL HI
JONES JONES HI LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE CASKEY. MAKOWSKI ARE AT
SEVEN ZERO. MOVING ON TO MISTER
BORDER US- SB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN STATE REGULATORY ACTION
PRODUCTION OUR WAIVER OF CIVIL
PENALTIES- IT'S A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WITH AMENDMENTS
PER AUTHOR TO MAKE REQUIREMENTS
CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION AND IT AND TO ADD
CO AUTHORS. SB FORTY FIFTY
SEVEN THE MOTIONS TO PASS AND
THE TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BATES AYE BRADFORD AYE
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL HI JONES
I JONES I LEYVA AYE LEYVA HI MY
COUNTY HI HOUSE KIANA SEVEN
ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT SEVEN TO
ZERO MOVING TO MISS CAVELL EURO
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
NEIGHBORHOOD HOMES ACT SAID-
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS FOR
THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO ADD A
CO AUTHOR BAND SHORT TERM
RENTAL OF UNITS. AND MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
AYE BATES. BATES AYE BRADFORD
ARE BRADFORD HOT HILL HI JONES
JONES I LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE
WIECKOWSKI AYE TRUSTEE. SEVEN
ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT SEVEN IS
A SB FOURTEEN NINE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD CAL INCOME CREDIT NON
FILERS. STRAIGHT TO PASS SB
FORTINO NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO HI TINA I BATES
BATES AYE BRADFORD. BRADFORD HI
BILL. HILL UP. I LAID AYE LEYVA
I MCAFEE HI CASKEY BY SEVEN
ZERO. THOSE OUT SO ZERO ON IS
CHIANG SB NINE TWO STATURE
LIMITATIONS- RECOMMENDATION IS
TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO
STRIKE RANSOMWARE FROM THE BILL
SB NINE TWENTY TO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES BATES FIVE
BRADFORD BRADFORD BY HILL HILL
AYE JONES. JONES BY WELL HI
LEYVA OUR CASKEY FIVE CASKEY
ARE. IT IS SEVEN ZERO. ARE YOU
MOVING ON WESTERN DOLLY SB NINE
TWENTY ONE STATE HIGHWAY
THROUGH ONE SEVENTY FOUR
RELINQUISHMENT SO STRAIGHT TO
PASS SB NINE TWENTY TWO I'M
SORRY ON THE ONE. THE NINE
TWENTY OF MY FILES. SB NINE
TWENTY ONE BY SENATOR DOLLY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
ALL RIGHT BATES. BATES ARE AYE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD ON HILL HILL
AYE JONES I JONES HI LEYVA AYE
LEYVA HI WHAT COUNTY HI CASKEY
ARE AT SEVENTY ZERO. MOVING ON
SB NINE EIGHTY NINE SIERRA
NEVADA CONSERVANCY BOUNDARY
EXPANSION A TO DO PASS SB NINE
EIGHT NINE MOTIONS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO ALRIGHT BATES. BATES
AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL
HILL AYE JONES I JONES ARE
LEYVA HI LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI
KATHY FIVE SEVENTY ZERO WAS OUT
SEVEN ZERO MOVING UP MISTER
DODD SB EIGHT SIXTY TWO DE
ENERGIZED COMMUNITY RESOURCE
CENTERS AND PUBLIC SAFETY TO
STRAIGHT TO PASS. SB EIGHT
SIXTY TWO IS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
I BATES BATES AYE BRADFORD AYE
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL AYE
JONES. JONES LEYVA AYE LEYVA I
WORK OUT BY. THE HOUR. SEVEN
ZERO. CLOSE OUT SEVEN IS HERE
AS A EIGHT EDUCATION FINANCE
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS
THAT'S A RECOMMENDATION TO PASS
WITH THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED
TO REMOVE THE DISASTER RELIEF
PROGRAM. SB EIGHT EIGHT FOR THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO I BATES. HI BATES
AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL HI JONES JONES HI LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE WERE COUNTY BY
COUNTY ARE. SB TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN NURSE MIDWIVES SCOPE OF
PRACTICE THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
MOVE THE BILL THE FOUR WITH A
MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO ESTABLISH
PARAMETERS AND PROTOCOLS FOR
INDEPENDENT PRACTICES OF
MIDWIFERY. SB TWO ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO I YOU KNOW I BATES
GAINES. BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL HILL HI JONES JONES HI
LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE WIECKOWSKI
AYE. ASKEY BY. SIX TO ZERO.
MOVING TO MISTER ROSS SO NOW
THAT THERE WAS OUT BY THE WAY
SIX ZERO MOVING THE MYSTERONS
SO SB ELEVEN ELEVEN ON
JUVENILES WITH AMENDMENTS TO
APPLY A CONSISTENT H. CAP UNDER
TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD THROUGHOUT
THE BILL. SB OPEN ELEVEN
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. IT'S NOW
BRADFORD FOR FIVE HILL HILL HI
JONES YEAH JONES NOVEL LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE WORK OWSKI HI
CASKEY ARE. FIVE TO TWO CALPERS
OUT FIVE TO SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE PUBLIC EMPLOYEE LABOR
RELATIONS EMPLOYEE INFORMATION
IT'S A TO PASS SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE MOTIONS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO
ALL RIGHT PORTANTINO AYE BATES
BATES NOW BRADFORD BRADFORD
HIGH HILL. HILL NO JONES JONES
NOW LEYVA AYE LEYVA HI MY
COUNTY HIGH. HEALTHY ARE. LOTUS
FORTY THREE IT WAS OUT FORTY
THREE SB ELEVEN NINETY
TENNESSEE TERMINATION A TO DO
PASS. SB ELEVEN NINETY MODE IS
TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
ALRIGHT BATES. BATES NO BREAD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL RIGHT
JONES JONES FLAVOR HI WAVE I
WANT HI HOUSE KEY I BOOKS. FIVE
TWO. THE BILL WAS OUT FIVE TO
TWO SB TWELVE SEVEN THE MASTER
SERVICE IN EMPLOYEES MEESE
EMPLOYMENT SAFETY STANDARDS AS
TO PASS. SB TWELVE FIVE TWELVE
FIFTY SEVEN MOTIONS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO I'D BATES. BATES NO
BRADFORD. EFFORTS ARE HILL HILL
HI JONES JONES NO LEYVA HI
LEYVA HI MY COFFEE HI MY COUNTY
BY. FIVE TO TWO OF THOSE ARE
FIVE TO TWO SB THIRTEEN NINETY
NINE EMPLOYMENT GARMENT
MANUFACTURING IT TO DO HOUSE.
NINETY NINE MOTIONS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO FIVE
TINA ON A BATES WELL BATES NOW
BRADFORD BRADFORD HI HILL HILL
OUR JONES JONES KNOWS LEYVA HI
LEYVA FIVE WERE CASKEY BY
ASKING WHY. IS FIVE TO CLOSE
OUT FIVE TO MOVING MISTER
GLAZER SB EIGHT A ONE DE
ENERGIZED MEDICAL BACK UP POWER
TO DO PASS SB EIGHT ZERO ONE
MOTIONS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
AYE IT'S- BATES NO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HILL HILL AYE JONES
JONES HELLO HI LEYVA MY COUNTY
HI ASKING ARE. THOSE FIVE TWO.
THE BULLS ARE FIVE TWO TWO SB
THIRTY TO ONE WORKS PROSECTOR
EDUCATION A- TO MAKE THE BILL
SUBJECT TO A BUDGET
APPROPRIATION. SB TWELVE THIRTY
TO THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BATES AYE BRADFORD ARE
BRADFORD AYE HILL. AYE JONES
I'VE JONES FIVE LEYVA HI LEYVA
I MY COUNTY I CAN'T KEEP BY BUT
SEVEN ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT
SEVEN ZERO WE HAVE A COMMITTEE
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS BILL SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR WHICH THE
RECOMMENDATION IS. TO PASS TO
THE STE THE SENATE WITH THE
MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO EXTEND
SPECIFIC APPOINTING AUTHORITY
AN EXAMINATION EXEMPTION BY ONE
YEAR. SB FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
I'M TINA ALL RIGHT BATES. BATES
AYE BRADFORD ARE BRADFORD AYE
HILL HILL ARE JONES JONES BY
LEYVA HI. IF I WERE COUNTY BY
COUNTY ARE. SEVEN ZERO BILLS
OUT SEVEN ZERO MOVING TO MS
GONZALEZ- SB ELEVEN THIRTY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND-
RECOMMENDATION IS THE BILL WITH
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE ELIGIBILITY
EXPANSION INTO IN UPON US OF. A
BIG RESOURCES SB ELEVEN THIRTY
THE MOTIONS TO PASS AMENDED THE
SENATE FOR PORTENT I PORTANTINO
ALRIGHT BAY. BATES NOW BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL. HILL HI JOE.
JONES NO LEYVA HI LEYVA I WANT
TO ASK HI MY COUNTY ARE. FIVE
TO TWO. FLOWS OUT FIVE THE TO
MOVING TO MISTER HERTZBERG SB
TEN SIXTY FIVE ON CAL WORKS
HOMELESSNESS WITH HE MEMONS
PER AUTHOR TO REMOVE ASSET TEST
AND RESTORE ONCE IN A TWELVE
MONTH TIME WOMEN TEND
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE IT SUBJECT
TO A BUDGET APPROPRIATION. SB
TEN SIXTY FIVE TO MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO. HI PORTANTINO
I'D BATES HI BATES AYE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES. JONES HI LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE WHAT COUNTY HI
CASKEY ARE. BOTH SEVEN ZERO.
BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO MOVING TO
MISTER HILL. SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE ON FOREVER TOBACCO
PRODUCTS WITH THE MEMBERS PER
AUTHORED WITH EXCEPT OUT
FLAVORED SHISHA. AT RETAILERS
AND ADD CO AUTHORS SHEESH. SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE TO MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO ARE BATES. THE
BRADFORD. AYE BRADFORD AYE HILL
HILL JONES. JONES NOVEL LEYVA
HI LEYVA IOWA CASKET HI ASKING
HI VOTERS FIVE TWO ONE FIVE TWO
ONE IN MISTER HILL COMPLIMENTS
TO YOU ON WORKING SO HARD ON A
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE. YOU GOT
IT SB ALIVE AND I WAS ONE OF
THOSE COME AUTHORS YEAH. SB
ELEVEN FIFTY NINE WORKERS
COMPENSATION COVERT NINETEEN
CRITICAL WORKERS WITH THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO CODIFY
THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
ON WORKERS COMPENSATION ON
COVERT NINETEEN. SB ELEVEN
FIFTY NINE THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. AS OF AND- LEVIN FIFTY
NINE ELEVEN FIFTY NINE. A BATES
NO BRADFORD. EFFORT BY HILL AYE
JONES JONES NO LEYVA I LEYVA
ARMOR. FIFTY FIVE VOTERS. FIVE
TWO. LOUIS ON MISTER AS TWELVE
THIRTY EIGHT CALTRAIN PAPER
STUDY WERE PLASTIC OF IMAGE
MAKE THE STATE PERMITS REVISED
THE STUDY PARAMETERS AND
REQUIRE ANNUAL PROGRESS REPORTS
TO THE LEGISLATURE. SB TWELVE
THIRTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO I DO KNOW I
BATES. BATES AYE BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL HI JONES
JONES I LEYVA HI LEYVA ARE YOUR
ACCOUNT HI COUNTY BY. SEVENTY
ZERO. THOSE OUT SEVEN ZERO SP
THIRTEEN A ONE TO ONE A RIVER
VALLEY BI NATIONAL WATERSHED
MANAGEMENT PLAN WITH THE
MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO MAKE IT
CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION. SB THIRTEEN OH
ONE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO.
I WANT TO KNOW AYE BATES BATES
AYE BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE
HILL. HILL AYE JONES. JONES NOT
LOADING. LEYVA AYE LEYVA HI MY
COUNTY HI KASKI ART THAT IS SIX
TO ZERO. THAT'S OUT SIX ZERO SB
FORTINO THREE ON HOME WHETHER
IS ATION FOR LOW INCOME
CUSTOMERS TO DO PASS SB FORTINO
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
FORTINO FIVE BATES. BRADFORD
RIGHT BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL HI
JONES. JONES NO LEYVA. HI LEYVA
I WORK OUT. HI PASSKEY BY THAT.
FIVE TWO ONE. THE BILL IS OUT
FIVE ONE WE IMAGE TANTO SB TEN
TWELVE ON IDLE. WELLS IT'S A
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. SB TEN
TWELVE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO I WANT TO KNOW I
BATES. HI BATES FIVE BRADFORD
BRADFORD ARE HILL HILL AYE
JONES JONES HI LEYVA HI LEYVA I
WORK OUT I ASKE BY. SEVEN ZERO
THE BILL WAS OUT SEVEN ZERO SB
ELEVEN OH THREE WORKFORCE
TRAINING PROGRAMS SUPPORT OF
SERVICES WITH A MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO REMOVE DSS AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. SB ELEVEN
OH THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BRADFORD RIGHT BRADFORD
AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE JONES.
JONES NOW LEYVA HI LEYVA ARMOR
CASKEY HI ASKING ARE. FIVE TO
ONE IT WAS OUT FIVE TWO ONE SB
TWELVE FIFTY NINE. ON TASK
FORCE FACILITIES SS I SS P. FOR
THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
SPECIFY TASK FORCE MEMBERSHIP
AND REPORT DUE DATE. SB TWELVE
FIFTY NINE THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO I WANT TO KNOW AYE
BATES. BATES AYE BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL. HILL AYE
JONES I'VE JONES ARE LEYVA AYE
LEYVA AYE AND WORK OUT HI ASKEY
ARE SEVEN ZERO. DOLLARS OUT
SEVEN ZERO- THERE'S A COMMITTEE
BILL SB TWELVE SIXTY FOUR
NEWMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE WITH
THE MEMONS PER AUTHOR TO
CLARIFY DEFINITIONS. SB TWELVE
SIXTY FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO. HI TINA ALL RIGHT
BATES BATES BY BRADFORD
BRADFORD BY HILL HILL PARK
JONES JONES ARE LEYVA HI FAVOR
I WORK OUT HI KATHY FIVE. SEVEN
ZERO AT THIS OUT SEVEN ZERO SP
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE ON CAL
GRANTS CAL WORKS GRANT FAMILY
REUNIFICATION WITH AMENDMENTS
TO MAKE IT SUBJECT TO A BUDGET
APPROPRIATION. SB THIRTEEN
FORTY ONE THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO HI TINA ALL RIGHT
BATES. BATES AYE BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL. YOU ARE
JONES JONES ARE AYE LEYVA AYE
LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI MY COUNTY
ARE AT SEVEN ZERO SEVEN SEVEN
ZERO MOVING THEM IS JACKSON SB
NINE FIFTY SIX. TAXATION TAX
EXPENDITURES CALIFORNIA TAX
EXPENDITURE REVIEW BOARD TO
STRAIGHT TO PASS SB NINE FIFTY
SIX MOTION TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO. HI
PORTANTINO ALRIGHT BATES. BATES
NOW BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL.
AYE JONES NO JONES NO LEYVA AYE
LEYVA AYE CASKET HI PASSKEY
OUR- VOTE IS FIVE TO TWO.
DOUBLES UP FIVE TO- SB NINE
SEVENTY THREE EMPLOYEE
EMPLOYERS ANNUAL REPORT. DATA
WITH A MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED
REQUIRE SUBMISSION OF DATA IN
ELECTRONIC FORMAT AND MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. SB NINE SO
THREE MOST TO PASS AS A MAN TO
THE CENTER FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES NOW
BRADFORD. EFFORT BY HILL HILL
HI JONES JONES NO LEYVA AYE
LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI CASKEY
ARE FIVE TO THE BILL'S OUT FIVE
TO TWO. SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE. EMPLOYEES TIME OFF FOR
THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO LIMIT
THE EMPLOYER SIZE AND TIME
EXPANSIONS TO DECLARE.
EMERGENCIES AND MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES BE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BATES NO BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL AYE
JONES. JONES NO LEYVA AYE AYE
WIECKOWSKI AYE CASKEY HI THAT'S
FIVE TO CLOSE OUT FIVE TO
MOVING ON TO MISTER JOHN LET'S
GET MR TRUMP SHOPPERS CAN. GIVE
THEM TO READ MAKE A MOTION AS
GET MESSAGE ON. WHO JUST
ALTHOUGH NO. IT'S OUR I WILL
MOVING ON TO MISTER JONES SB
EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS LICENSING
APPLICATION WAIT TIMES AT SAID
TO PASS FOR THE MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES AND PROVIDE A DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION DATE. SB EIGHT
SEVEN EIGHT THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO HI TINA ALL RIGHT
BATES BATES ALRIGHT BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AVE HILL. HILL ALL
RIGHT JONES. JONES I LEYVA WEEK
I. OUR Y. CASCADE FIGHT BASS
GUITAR LISTEN YOUR TOP SEVEN
ZERO DOES OUT SEVEN ZERO SB TEN
TWENTY FOUR OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLES COMPETITION BIKES IT'S
A STRAIGHT TO PASS A THREE TEN
TWENTY FOUR THE MOTIONS TO PASS
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
TINA ALL RIGHT BATES. BATES ICE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL
HILL HI JONES JONES BY LEYVA
AYE LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI
CASKEY. ALL RIGHT MOVING ON
AVENUE. THAT'S BILLS OUT SEVEN
SEVEN ZERO MOVING ON TO MISS
LEYVA SB NINE FIFTEEN MOBILE
HOME PARK COPE WITH EMERGENCY
RELIEF- THE BILL THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO MOVE IT TO
THE SENATE FLOOR WITH
AMENDMENTS TO ALLOW THE PARTIES
TO AGREE TO A DIFFERENT
REPAYMENT TIME FRAME AND TO
SPECIFY THAT EVICTIONS ARE
ALLOWED FOR VIOLATIONS THAT
MATERIALLY THREATEN PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY. SB NINE ONE
FIVE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO
HI. FOURTEEN A I BATES. BATES
NOW BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE
HILL. HILL AYE JONES. JONES NO
LEYVA. I DOUBLE THE HIGH BAR I
CAN'T GET BY WITHOUT SKI FINE.
FIVE TO TWO. THE BILL IS OUT
FIVE TO TWO. WE'RE MOVING ON SB
TWELVE THIRTEEN PEOPLE
INSTRUCTIONS SOCIAL SCIENCES AT
THE TO PASS SB TWELVE THIRTEEN
EMOTIONS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO ON PORTANTINO
ALRIGHT BATES BATES AYE
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL
HI JONES. I'VE JONES I LEYVA HI
LEYVA I AND MY COUNTY HIGH
RISKY ARE THAT'S SEVEN ZERO.
ONE ONE SECULAR BILLS OUT SEVEN
ZERO. ONE SECOND. OKAY MCGUIRE
MISTER MCGUIRE- SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY NINE CONTRACTING
BUSINESS HOME IMPROVEMENT
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY WITH THE
MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO ADD
CLARIFYING CHANGES. SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY NINE THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO BY PORTANTINO ON AYE
BATES AYE BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL HI JONES
I'VE JONES ARE LEYVA HI LEYVA
HI MY COUNTY HI MY COUNTY ARE.
SEVEN ZERO. OPPOSE OUT SEVEN
ZERO SB ELEVEN NINETY NINE
COMMISSION ON HOME HARDING THE
MEMBERS PER AUTHORED TO REMOVE
THE MANDATE DISCOUNTS AND
MANDATORY POLICY RENEWALS AND
MAKE OTHER CHANGES TO THE
COMMISSION. SB ELEVEN NINETY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR HI
I'M SORRY PORTANTINO. AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. NO NO
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL
AYE JONES JONES NO LEYVA AYE
LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI ASKING
ARE. THAT IS FIVE TO TWO THOSE
ARE FIVE TO SB THIRTEEN TWELVE
ALTHOUGH THE IT'S A STRAIGHT TO
PASS RECOMMENDATION I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE PARTIES ARE
NEGOTIATING IN EARNEST AND MY
EXPECTATION IS THAT- THEY'LL BE
SOME MOVEMENT ON HOW THAT
PROGRESSES AND I KNOW THAT
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN THE
NEXT COUPLE DAYS SO. THAT TO DO
PASS WITH- STRONG HOPES OF SOME
MOVEMENT. SB THIRTEEN TWELVE
THE MOTIONS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO
AYE BATES. THEY'LL BATES NO
BRADFORD. HELLO HILL I JONES
JONES NO LEYVA HI LEYVA HI MY
COUNTY HI ASKING BY VOTERS
FORTY TWO. IMPROPER THE BILL IS
OUT FORTY TWO. SPREAD PRETTY
ONE A STATE WHERE YOU WERE ON
THE. WELL NOT FORGET FORGET
FORGET JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I
DIDN'T WANT TO GO THROUGH THE
ROLE IF YOU WERE GONNA ALRIGHT
MOVING ON MISTER MINING. SB
NINE SEVEN SEVEN THIS BILLS OUT
WITH AMENDMENTS AUTHORIZED SIX
X. AN EXPEDITED REVIEW FOR
SPECIFIED ACADEMIC MEDICAL
CENTERS AND CLARA CON OF
INTEREST PROVISIONS FOR THE
BOARD MEMBERS. SB NINE SEVEN
SEVEN EMOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BATES NOW BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL AYE
JONES JONES NO LEYVA HI LEYVA
HI MY COUNTY HI CASKEY ARE.
VERY CHERRY NOW. FIVE THE TWO
THAT BILLS OUT FIVE TO TWO
ALWAYS IS GO TO THE AMEN RIGHT-
MISTER NIELSEN'S SB NINE FIFTY
TWO SALES AND USE TAX
EXEMPTIONS BACK UP ELECTRICAL
GENERATORS DISTRICTING PASS.
FIFTY NINE FIVE TO MOTIONS TO
PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO HI TINA ALL RIGHT
BATES BATES AYE BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL. HILL HI
JONES JONES HI LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE WHAT KIND OF QINGHAI CASKEY.
FIVE SEVEN ZERO IT WAS OUT
SEVEN ZERO MOVING TO DOCTOR PAN
SB EIGHT FIFTY TWO OFFICE OF
DRUG CONTRACTING IN
MANUFACTURING WITH THE MEMBERS
FOR AUTHOR. TO CLARIFY
FEDERALLY FUNDED REBATES ARE
ALLOWABLE. SB EIGHT FIVE TO
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. THEY
BRADFORD OR BRADFORD AYE HILL
HILL AYE JONES JONES NOW LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE WERE CASKEY HI
ALFIE ARE IS FIVE TWO ONE. THE
BILL IS OUT FIVE TWO ONE MOVING
TO SOME GUY NAMED PORTANTINO SB
NINE FOURTEEN FIREARMS TO PASS.
NINE SB NINE ONE FOUR MOTIONS
TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO. AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BATES NOW BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL AYE
JONES JONES NO LEYVA HI LEYVA
HI MY COUNTY HI KATHY HI FIVE
TO. A CLOSE OUT FIVE THE TWO SP
TWELVE NINETY NINE ON HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT INCENTIVES FOR
REZONING IDLE COMMERCIAL
PROPERTIES THERE'S A MEMBERS
PER AUTHORED AND CO AUTHORS AND
SIMPLIFY THE GUIDELINE ADOPTION
PROCESS SB TWELVE NINETY NINE
THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO
HI. YOU KNOW I BATES BATES AYE
BRADFORD BY BRADFORD AYE HILL
HILL AYE JONES JONES UP LEYVA
AYE LEYVA HI MY COFFEE HI WHAT
KIND OF GUITAR THAT'S ONE TO
ZERO THOSE OUT SEVEN ZERO
MOVING THEM IS RUBIO. SB ELEVEN
FORTY ONE ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
COERCIVE. CONTROL TO DO PASS.
SB ALLOW FORTY ONE MOTIONS TO
PASS THIS FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO ONLINE BATES. EIGHT
FIVE BRADFORD BRADFORD BY
GUILT. HILL HI JONES JONES HI
LEYVA HI LEYVA I WORK OUT HI
KATHY OUR SEVEN ZERO THE BILL
IS OUT SEVEN ZERO- MS RIVERA
COMMITTEE- I'M INSURANCE BILL
SB. TWELVE FIFTY FIVE STRAIGHT
TO PASS. SB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE
MOTIONS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO
AYE BATES BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL. HILL I JONES
JONES I LEYVA HI LEYVA HI
MICHAEL HI SB ONLINE SEVENTY
ZERO. WAS OUT SEVEN ZERO SB OUR
MOVING ANIMIST SKINNER SB TEN
SIXTY FOUR ON PRISON
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMANTS SO
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO STRIKE
THE O. I. G. AUDITS. SB TEN
SIXTY FOUR THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BATES NOW BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL AYE
JONES. JON SNOW LEYVA HI LEYVA
AYE WORKERS HI ACCOUNTS BY FIVE
TO THOSE OUT FIVE TO SB TEN
SEVENTY NINE AND RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTY FOR CLOSURES- THERE'S
A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO STRIKE
THE REQUIREMENTS ON EACH CD. SB
TEN SEVENTY NINE EMOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO I PORTANTINO
ALRIGHT BATES. BATES NO
BRADFORD EFFORT BY HILL HILL
AYE JONES JONES NO LEYVA HI
LEYVA I WORK OUT HI CASKEY BY
FIVE TO CLOSE OUT FIVE TO SB
TEN EIGHTY FIVE DENSITY BONUS
LAW INCENTIVE ENHANCEMENTS SO
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO DELETE
THE AUTHORITY FOR DEVELOPERS TO
MAKE CERTAIN DETERMINATIONS AND
TO MAKE A CLARIFYING CHANGE. SB
TEN EIGHTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE BRADFORD UP FOR
BRADFORD AYE SORRY BATES
ABSTAINED. IF ANY THAT ADVANCE-
HILL HILL AYE JONES JONES NO
LEYVA AYE. LEYVA HI MY COUNTY
HI THIS GUITAR. VOTERS FIVE TO
ONE. BUT WAS OUT BY THE ONE
DOING TO MR STERN SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE PROHIBITION ON
IMPORTATION IN POSSESSION OF
WILD ANIMALS. AND THERE'S A
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO REMOVE
DFW STUDY REQUIREMENTS. SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE THE MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BRADFORD
OUR BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL ARE
JONES JONES NO LEYVA AYE LEYVA
I WORK OUT HI OKAY BYE. IT IS
FIVE TO ONE IT WAS OUT FIVE TO
ONE MOVING ON SB TWELVE FIFTEEN
NON ELECTRIC MICHAEL GRAVES
THERE'S A MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO
NARROW THE SCOPE APPLY ONLY TO
CERTAIN HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS.
SB TWELVE FIFTEEN MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO HI TINA ALL
FIVE RATES. BATES NO BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL HI JONES
JONES NO LEYVA AYE LEYVA HI MY
COUNTY HI OF KEEP FAR. IS FIVE
TWO TWO IT WAS OUT FIVE TO TWO
SB THIRTEEN TWENTY CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE CHANGE ASSESSMENTS WHEN
THE MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
REQUIRE PORT REPORTS. ONCE
EVERY FIVE YEARS AN AMENDMENT
TO MAKE IT CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATIONS. SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY FOR MOTIONS TO PASS IS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO ALL RIGHT PORTANTINO
AYE BATES. BATES BY BRADFORD
BRADFORD BY HILL. HILL ARE
JONES JONES NO LEYVA AYE LEYVA
ALRIGHT WE CAN SKI HI A SKI
ARE. THIRTY SIX TO ONE WITHOUT
SIXTY ONE WE'RE GONNA SB
THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT ON FIRE
PREVENTION WITH THE MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES
SB THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI TINA
ALL RIGHT BATES. NO TAPES NOW
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL HI JONES JONES NO LEYVA
AYE LEYVA ARE CASKEY HI RESCUE
ARE FIVE TO TWO. CLOSE OUT FIVE
TO MOVING ON TO MISTER NUMBER
SB NINE EIGHTY ON PRIVACY DNA
TESTING THERE'S AMENDMENTS TO
MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES. SB NINE
EIGHTY MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. THE BRADFORD OUR
BRADFORD AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
JONES JONES NOW LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE WIECKOWSKI HI OF FIVE. FIVE
SB ELEVEN NINETY SIX ON PRICE
GOUGING WITH THE MEMBERS TO
SUNSET THE FELONY PUNISHMENT TO
ALLOW FOR AN ADJUSTMENT FOR
INFLATION. SB ELEVEN NINETY SIX
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
TINA ALL RIGHT BATES. IT'S NOW
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL
AYE JONES JONES NO LEYVA AYE
LEYVA AYE WIECKOWSKI HI KATHY
FIVE. FIVE TO TWO BUT THOSE ARE
FIVE TO SB TWELVE TWENTY ON
PEACE AND CUSTODIAL OFFICERS
THERE'S A MEMBERS PER AUTHORED
A DEFINED MORAL TURPITUDE AND
REQUIRE OFFICER NOTICES IN
DISPUTE OPPORTUNITIES TAKE
PLACE BEFORE PLACING AN OFFICER
ON THE BRADY LAST TWELVE TWENTY
TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS IS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO. AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. THEY BRADFORD. HELLO
WELL I JONES JONES NO LEYVA AYE
LEYVA AYE WIECKOWSKI HI CASKEY
ARE FOR ONE BILLS OUT FOUR TO
ONE MOVING ON THE MISTER WHITE
COUNT SKI MISTER WHITE COW SKI
HOW ARE YOU ONE BILL ONE OF THE
LAW ONE BILL BOB. SB NINE OH
EIGHT DEBT COLLECTORS LICENSING
AND REGULAR DEBT COLLECTION
LICENSEE ACT WITH THE MEMBERS
FOR AUTHOR TO DECREASE
EXAMINATION FREQUENCY AND
AUTHORIZED THE COMMISSION TO
CONDUCT REMOTE EXAMINATIONS.
THREE NINE ZERO EIGHT MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI YOU
KNOW WHY BATES HI STATE HI
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE HILL
HILL AYE JONES JONES NO LEYVA
HI LEYVA HI MY COUNTY HI CASKEY
ARE SIXTY ONE. WAS OUT SIX TO
ONE MOVING THE MISTER WINNER SB
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE HEALTH
COVERAGE MENTAL HEALTH OR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS WHEN
THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO
CLARIFY CITY I ENFORCEMENT
LANGUAGE AND DEFINITIONS. SB
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO I AM
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES NOW
BRADFORD PARK BRADFORD AYE HILL
HILL AYE JONES JONES NO LEYVA
AYE LEYVA I WANT TO ASK. HI
KATHY OUR- VOTERS FIVE TWO
CLOSE OUT FIVE TO MOVE SB EIGHT
NINE NINE AFFORDABLE. JOINT
DEVELOPMENTS ON NONPROFIT LIVE
RELIGIOUS HOSPITAL IN COLLEGE
LANDS WITH THE MEMONS PER
AUTHORED TO REMOVE HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES LIMIT TO LANCE
CURRENTLY OWNED BY ELIGIBLE
ENTITIES. REQUIRE CONFORMITY
WITH LOCALS ONLY STANDARDS AND
SPECIFY OTHER REQUIREMENTS AND
RESTRICTIONS. SB EIGHT NINETY
NINE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO
HI PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES
I'D BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL
HILL AYE JONES JONES I LEYVA
AYE WE ARE WE'RE COUNTY HI OKAY
FIVE SEVEN ZERO GOES OUT SEVEN
ZERO. SB NINE OH TWO LOCAL
ZONING ORDINANCES TEN UNITS PER
PARCEL. IT IS A TO PASS SB NINE
OH TO THE MOTIONS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
TINA I BATES. BATES NO BRADFORD
BRADFORD FIVE HILL HILL AYE
JONES. TRUMP HI LEYVA I LEYVA I.
AYE CAN MCCARTHY ARE SIX TO
ONE. DOES SIX TO ONE MOVING
THAT NINE THIRTY TWO COBRA DATA
COLLECTION MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR
TO ADD URGENCY COSTAS FIVE
REPORTING TOOL AND CLARIFY
DEFINITIONS SB NINE THIRTY TO
THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO
ALL RIGHT PORTANTINO I BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL HILL HI JONES JONES HI
LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE WIECKOWSKI
HI KATHY BY. SEVEN ZERO. ALL
RIGHT SB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
HOUSING ELEMENT ZONING FOR
EMERGENCY SHELTERS TO DO PASS.
SB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT MOTIONS
TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BATES NOW BRADFORD PARK
BRADFORD AYE HILL. TO OUR
JONES. JONES NOW LEYVA HI LEYVA
HI MY CASKET HIGH FIFTY ARE.
LOS FIVE TO THOSE OUT FIVE TO
TWO. SHOULD WE MAKE MISTER ROCK
WONDER. SHOULD WE KNOW WE'LL
HAVE OTHER THINGS TO WITH GOV
REALLY. YOUR THIS AND I'D LIKE
TO MAKE MY FLIGHT I STILL HAVE
TO GET ELECTIONS LARA CAN
MISTER WELCOME LEVIN FIFTEEN
COMMERCIAL BLOOD BANKS FOR
ANIMALS ANIMAL BLOOD DONORS FOR
THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO
INCREASE THE FEE AND MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. SB ELEVEN
FIFTEEN MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO HI TINA ON AYE BATES
BATES AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL HILL ARE JONES I JONES ART
LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE AND MARKUPS
BY ASKING THAT IS SEVEN ZERO.
I'M WE PAUSE FOR JUST MOMENT
CENTER. I'M SORRY YOUR PAUSE
FOR JUST A MOMENT THE BILLS OUT
SEVEN ZERO.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING TO RECESS FOR FIVE
MINUTES BE BACK HERE IN FIVE
MINUTES.
WE'RE GONNA GO BACK
INTO ORDER. AND I AM GOING TO
ASK FOR UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RECONSIDER THE VOTE ON SB NINE
NINE FIVE. LET THE RECORD SHOW
THAT I HAD UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RECONSIDER SB NINE NINE FIVE SO
NOW WE ARE GOING TO THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS SB
NINE NINE FIVE BY SENATOR
ATKINS. WITH A MEMBER INSTEAD
CO AUTHORS. YOU WANT A SECOND.
THE GUYS IN THE SECOND- SHE HAS
THE POTION ON REPEAL IT IS NOT
OUR WE DID THE MAN AND
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RECONSIDER
SO THAT'S THE- ACTOR. OKAY AND
THEN I WAS ABOUT TO READ WHERE
THE MOTION IS TO DO PASS WITH
CO AUTHORS DEFINING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND ADD LANGUAGE
REGARDING THE USE OF SKILLED
AND TRAINED LABOR. AN OFFICE IN
OFFICE THOSE ARE AUTHOR
AMENDMENTS. OKAY SO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
WITH AUTHORS AMENDMENTS THAT CO
AUTHORS TO FIND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND ADD LANGUAGE
REGARDING THE USE OF SKILLED
AND TRAINED LABOR EVERYBODY ON
THE SAME PAGE HERE. ALL RIGHT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SB NINE
NINE FIVE THE MOTION IS GOING
TO BE TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO ALL
RIGHT PORTANTINO HI BATES. I'D
SAY TO THE SENATE FOR AS
AMENDED CORRECT BRADFORD OUR
BRADFORD AYE HILL. HILL AYE
JONES. JONES NO LEYVA LEYVA I
WORK OWSKI I CASKEY II THE VOTE
IS FIVE TO ONE THE BILL IS OUT
FIVE TWO ONE AS AMENDED ALSO I
WOULD LIKE UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RECONSIDER THE VOTE ON SB NINE
OH EIGHT SEEING NOBODY OBJECT
WE HAVE UNANIMOUS CONSENT I
WOULD LIKE TO RE VOTE ON SB
NINE OH EIGHT WITH A MEMBERS
PER AUTHORED OR DECREASE THE
EXAMINATION. FREQUENCY AND
AUTHORIZED THE COMMISSION TO
CONDUCT REMOTE EXAMINATIONS SB
NINE AWAIT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO
AYE BATES. BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE HILL. HILL AYE JONES. JONES
NO LEYVA HI LEYVA ARTWORK OWSKI
HI CASKEY ARE THE VOTE IS FIVE
TWO ONE THE BILL IS OUT FIVE
TWO ONE I SEE NO OTHER BUSINESS
BEFORE US WE WILL BE BACK HERE
NINE AM ON TUESDAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU COMMITTEE
THANK YOU- MEMBERS AND STAFF
AND EVERYBODY HAVE A GREAT
WEEKEND. THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.